i spoke to prince edward the duke of
edinburgh's
youngest son who told me that they were
still keeping their fingers crossed but
he was certainly feeling
a lot better now in the last few moments
we have actually just had
an official update from buckingham
palace as well so i'll read that to you
now
which says that the duke of edinburgh as
we know remains at the king edward vii
hospital and they say where he's
receiving medical attention for
an infection and he is comfortable and
responding to treatment but is not
expected to leave hospital um for
several days so
one thing that i do notice in that
statement is they have confirmed that he
is being treated for an infection of
course previously they hadn't given us
any details about what symptoms he was
being treated for
except for saying and that it wasn't
covid uh related we also know that he
has now been here at the king edward the
seventh hospital
um for seven days after he was brought
here by car not brought here by
ambulance we were told at the time that
it wasn't
an emergency um admission and also we
were told
a week ago that he was actually in good
spirits but
yeah as they're saying today they say he
is comfortable and
responding to treatment but what was
also interesting earlier on today
um is i actually caught up with as i
said prince edward who is the duke's
youngest
son i was talking to him actually for a
story that i'm doing about the duke of
edinburgh
awards scheme which we will run later on
this week but
his father was doing this is what he had
to say to me
your father the duke of edinburgh is in
hospital at the moment
um do you mind me asking how he is at
the moment
um well as far as i'm aware but i did
speak to him the other day so he's he's
he's a lot better thank you very much
indeed and and uh so
and he's looking forward to getting out
which is which is the most positive
thing so
we keep our fingers crossed since
frustration at being in hospital
just a bit i think that gets to all of
us so and then
that uh um so yeah you can you can only
watch the clock
so many times and and you know the walls
are only so interesting
well we all wish him well you're very
kind thank you very much steven thank
you
we've had some brilliant and lovely
messages from all sorts of people and
and we really appreciate that so
uh and and so to see i've been passing
them on so it's fantastic thank you